y
[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a los observadores de
france 24 esta semana vamos a gabón este
país centroafricano es rico en petróleo
un recurso que ha sido explotado por
empresas extranjeras durante más de 80
años una de ellas es total que vendió la
mayor parte de sus acciones a la empresa
británica brno hace dos años pero ahora
algunas personas denuncian la
consecuencia de las actividades de esas
empresas explica nuestra periodista
licelott más
con el pasado mes de octubre soplaban
vientos de revuelta en una zona
petrolífera en el occidente de gabón
donde los habitantes están cansados de
los derrames de petróleo que aseguran
fueron causados por la empresa perenco
nuestro observador es productor de cine
hizo un documental sobre esta situación
a un lado
[Música]
el petróleo sale de aquí pero no se hace
nada por la gente de aquí
perenco no ha hecho nada en este país
queremos que paren con los de los medios
para comer nuestros hijos están
desempleados y nosotros mismos nos vemos
damnificados
[Música]
hola me llamo bernard cristian regular
soy emprendedor miembro de la sociedad
civil
hoy quisiera hablarles de un tema que me
importa mucho que es la contaminación
por petróleo en una región de mi país de
gabón en la región de timbó web es pura
contaminación miren véanlo por ustedes
mismos ven
eso es petróleo crudo
esta contaminación se caracteriza por la
destrucción de los manglares hay capas y
capas de crudo que se superponen esta
contaminación también se materializa en
la muerte de cientos de especies de
animales peces camarones o cangrejos
miren ahí hay una huella de antílope acá
hay una
allá hay otra vienen a beber con
frecuencia aquí pero desafortunadamente
está contaminado así que la gente que
pesca que esencialmente se gana la vida
pescando cuando hay por ejemplo derrames
de petróleo las redes terminan
completamente llenas de peces muertos
llenos de petróleo crudo no hay bosques
enteros ríos que están contaminados hay
árboles que se mueren totalmente secos
casi todos los meses hay algún tipo de
contaminación en la región
no es él
están en pueblos cercanos a zonas donde
la presencia de h2s sulfuro de hidrógeno
es muy concentrada estuve en alguno de
esos pueblos pero les aseguro que no
pudimos pasar más de 30 minutos allá
teníamos náuseas dolor de cabeza eso que
hay ahí detrás es petróleo es perenco
el principal contaminador de estas
regiones perenco sin embargo estos pozos
de petróleo funcionan desde hace 80 años
por lo que asumo que hay un gran
problema de mantenimiento porque aunque
no soy ningún experto he visto cabezas
de pozos con filtraciones por todas
partes por todas partes
y estas poblaciones después de varios
años de contaminaciones recurrentes ya
están cansadas ya están cansadas de ver
como sus quejas no son escuchadas por
las autoridades locales las autoridades
competentes ni por perenco que es el
principal culpable
[Música]
así que se hartaron y decidieron formar
un colectivo crear una especie de
observatorio en cada pueblo y grabar
ellos mismos los diferentes tipos de
contaminación
y contactamos a la compañía
franco-británica perenco para saber más
sobre estos casos de contaminación no
respondieron a nuestras peticiones
en etiopía el conflicto de la región de
tigre tuvo lugar en dicho territorio con
enfrentamientos violentos pero también
en internet donde circula mucha
información falsa nos lo explica
alexandre y acá pronto será este vídeo
muestra el momento en el que un avión de
combate etíope es derribado por las
fuerzas del tigre
el frente de liberación popular craig
derribó un avión del ejército nacional
le dio pero piano
desde principios de noviembre se han
producido enfrentamientos entre las
fuerzas armadas etíopes y las fuerzas
disidentes del frente de liberación
popular de tigre en este contexto los
internautas compartieron dos vídeos para
demostrar que las fuerzas rebeldes
destruyeron los aviones etíopes que
bombardeaban la región para encontrar de
dónde viene este vídeo se debe utilizar
una herramienta de búsqueda como invite
y solo hay que copiar el vínculo del
vídeo y pegarlo en la plataforma la
plataforma muestra capturas de pantalla
que permiten buscar dónde se ha
publicado el vídeo
al hacer esta búsqueda vemos que el
vídeo fue publicado a principios de
noviembre de 2020 y fue presentado como
un avión derribado por las fuerzas
libias por lo tanto estas imágenes han
sido utilizadas en contextos diferentes
al seguir buscando finalmente
encontramos el vídeo en youtube el vídeo
es mucho más nítido y se ve que son
imágenes generadas por computador y por
una buena razón
estas imágenes provienen del videojuego
arma 3 este es un segundo vídeo de un
supuesto avión derribado por las fuerzas
de tigre fue visto más de 170 mil bs
sentidos
pero una vez más se trata de imágenes
del videojuego
[Música]
en resumen estos dos vídeos no tienen
absolutamente ninguna conexión con los
combates en la región de tigre de
etiopía cuando vean imágenes de combates
pregúntese siempre si acaso no son
imágenes de un videojuego este tipo de
contenido es una fuente frecuente de
desinformación en los conflictos armados
de los cuales se tienen pocas imágenes
eso fue todo los observadores de esta
semana todos nuestros contactos aparecen
en pantalla y si quiere enviarnos sus
fotos y vídeos y aficionados no lo dude
en contactarnos para mostrarnos lo que
ocurre cerca de ustedes hasta pronto
[Música]